all right dexter new blood it's done
i've sat on it i've slept on it i got me
some thoughts first of all spoiler
warning gonna talk about spoilers for
dexter new blood if you haven't seen
dexter new blood and you want to or
you're curious you should do that first
then come back to this video long story
short even if it wasn't on your radar if
you are a dexter fan i think you should
still watch the show because it's
it's by and large a great season of
dexter i spoil the warnings done you've
been warned now we're going to talk
about some spoilers in dexter which
means i know people just want me to talk
about the ending and i will i'm gonna at
least touch on what i felt or thought
about the season as a whole and i mean
it the season as a whole i thought it
was a really intriguing great return to
form to dexter had a lot of dexter stuff
that i loved from dexter when it was in
his prime that is seasons one through
four that's dexter prime for me great
intrigue great mystery dexter trying to
stay one step ahead of law enforcement
in which his girlfriend is a part of law
enforcement so there's that complexity
it was a case of giving you more of what
you love but also the character's aged
for 10 years you know as you said he's
an evolved monster he's in a bit of a
different place also harrison being 15
who has found him there's that added
complexity and dynamic all the while
there's a new serial killer out there
they have that passive-aggressive tug of
war going back and forth where it's like
i know who you are you know that i know
i know that you know that i know but
we're not gonna let anyone else know
that we know and so we're just gonna
make a little remarks and comments to
each other in public i thought that was
cool also harrison i thought he was well
cast because there's something about
you're like
is he saying he's like oh hannah died a
couple years ago of cancer my first
reaction was
you promise
there's a lot of that intrigue of not
knowing i knew what the [ __ ] is going on
here why is kirk caldwell saying he saw
his son when clearly he absolutely did
not and the end was actually really
intense i was gripping my couch the
entire time and then dexter gets shot in
the heart by harrison and killed so
dexter new blood have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
right if i ended my video right there
with that it would feel very abrupt very
unfulfilling people would be like i just
why did i watch that video enter the end
of dexter new blood which i will say
that dialogue between harrison and
dexter before that all went down i
thought it was good dialogue a couple of
great lines in there where harrison's
like you don't have a dark passenger
it's a driver and i was like that's a
really good point i'm glad they
addressed that also when harrison says
open your eyes and look at what you've
done it's a great callback to the pilot
episode when dexter says that to the
first person we see him kill open your
eyes and look at what you did but also i
thought logan died from a ricochet logan
in this show like the nicest friend guy
the nicest person ever i thought when
dexter had him in a choke hold and logan
shot i thought he he got ricocheted
about the bullet ricocheted and killed
him i thought he got dark knight rises
but apparently dexter broke his neck
which i was like oh that changes things
granted it's rule number one of the code
for a reason rule number one what's rule
number one of the code don't get caught
by implication that means okay so if
these other rules of the code get in the
way of rule number one rule number one
wins but i will argue that he didn't
have to kill him he could have just
given him choke hold and be like go to
sleep go to sleep go to sleep go to
sleep sweet thank you for the keys
goodbye but i did like seeing that
that dexter morgan with no mask
whatsoever he's like a feral animal with
his foot in a trap and he's gnawing that
foot off to get the [ __ ] out of dodge i
thought that was really cool glad i saw
it for 10 minutes now gonna be real with
you i've always understood and agreed
with clyde phillips concept that dexter
morgan would end up going down he would
go down in the end he said in an
interview the end that he was taking
dexter to was him in the electorate
chair surrounded by all the people he
killed you know he's hallucinating he's
seeing them granted the road getting
dexter to there involves a manhunts a
police chase a trial you know there's a
lot to do there a lot more than the last
part of the last episode shooting him in
the heart can contain and that's part of
the disappointment of dexter dying here
at least for me there's more to a
character going down than them just
dying they're just getting shot in the
heart that's not fulfillment it's it's
all about reputation seeing dexter's
friends know that this person that
brought them donuts on a daily basis is
actually a serial killer that feeling of
betrayal and now they gotta hunt this
person they considered a friend that's
actually pretty intense it's not the
death of the body it's the compromising
of the reputation in the eyes of the
people and the friends he had that's the
thing where breaking bad excelled at and
in that breaking bad kind of way i
always felt the same way about dextre
you know watching breaking bad i never
got the sense of like yeah this guy's
totally gonna get away with it forever i
always felt like walter white was doomed
to go down in the end that's always how
i felt about dexter but again it's all
about execution and i just felt the
execution at the end of this season was
way too abrupt for me to feel that
feeling of fulfillment i don't know why
it was so abrupt why they were like oh
no it's just going to be the end of this
one season maybe they didn't know if
they were going to get a season 2. we're
like but there are no superheroes in
this show there are no capes anywhere
does anyone give a [ __ ] about dexter
anymore it turns out they do a lot of
people clocked into showtime to watch
dexter new blood i'm glad about that but
in a world where they didn't know
they're probably like all right we have
one season to do all this stuff and hope
it works out which lesson right there
film two endings one reduction gets
killed and it's very abrupt you know
because it's a one-off or another one
where dexter slips through the cracks
and now everyone who knew him everyone
from this small town in upstate new york
miami metropd the fbi everyone's going
after dexter on the other hand maybe
they felt like a dexter manhunt wouldn't
really feel like dexter nor would the
trial of dexter morgan maybe a courtroom
drama wouldn't feel like a dexter show
but i would clock into that show like a
[ __ ] clyde phillips and crew
built dexter new blood and its
resolution around the father-son dynamic
with dexter and harrison which is much
smaller more intimate and very this
season it's very dexter new blood
whereas the mulligan resolution for the
rest of the series of the original
dexter gets lost under that and if i'm
venturing a guess
i really think fans required more
resolution with the original dexter
series side of things and granted a lot
of that fulfillment like i have wants
that i'm left wanting by the end of
dexter new blood obviously but they're
wants that i just can't have fulfilled a
lot of the people that would have been
really intriguing to watch them go after
dexter morgan they're dead now you're
not so we're dealing with an imperfect
deck of cards here that said given
dexter new blood there are things i feel
they could have done that would have
made it more palatable for fans like
angel batista right out the gate that's
one thought that i have it wasn't even
on my mind when dexter new blood started
that angel batista and dexter morgan
would ever have a face to face but then
angel batista was briefly in one episode
then angel batiste it was briefly in the
last episode in which he's like i'll fly
out in the morning i'll tell you
everything i know and he has this file
right there angel batista and dexter
morgan having that face to face would
have brought resolution with the miami
metro pd side of things you know side of
the deception i mean we're not going to
get deborah morgan hunting dexter morgan
which i think would have been pretty
epic i also think that they were setting
up for that lundy talking to her i think
it was in season four he's like you're
just like me the manhunt is that's what
drives you i was like oh they're setting
that up big time oh guess not so okay we
can't always get what we want but if you
try sometimes you'll find you get what
you need angel batista and dexter morgan
having that face to face where angels
like you are the bay harbor butcher my
wife is dead because of you dokes you
let dokes take the fall for your
killings your murders that would have
been a really important dialogue i would
have been something fans i feel needed
but it just never happened funny enough
a big part of this resolution in concept
is going to happen in the world of
dexter just off screen angel bautista
will know that dexter morgan is the bay
harbor butcher reopen the bay harbor
butcher case you know absolve james
doakes of those murders but it's not
knowing it'll happen it's seeing it you
know that's that's that feeling of
fulfillment that fans get i mean you do
get a sense of that oh he was our friend
and he totally lied to all of us in the
new crew and it does work in that
capacity but it's not the miami metro pd
crew would have been great to see these
two stories come together where they're
all like oh my god this guy right let's
get them and as much as i'd understand
where they're coming from as their
hunting dexter i would be rooting for
dexter cause who am i kidding i would be
but he wouldn't get away with it and
that'd be the tragedy of it all also
harrison shooting him in the chest just
like right there i was like okay well
that's well first of all it's a heart
shot so there's no question he's dead
but also i think it would have been
cooler if harrison was like nope i'm not
shooting you or a kneecaps or something
just blam it's like you're going back to
florida and you are going to answer for
these crimes however they wanted to do
it harrison not killing dexter i think
would have been more profound because
he'd be breaking the cycle he's like no
i'm not going to kill you i'm breaking
the cycle now harry taught you to kill
and get away with it you've been killing
and getting away with it you're telling
me to kill you but i'm not gonna kill
you the sins of the father end today in
an episode called sins of the father but
now harrison shoots him in the chest and
drives off somewhere i mean they're
probably setting up for a show where
harrison's some vigilante killer maybe
he doesn't have the ritualistic murder
thing down but you know he's killing bad
people because he feels bad people
should die so now in a world where
they're probably setting up for a
spin-off show starring harrison i
imagine is going to throw a lot of money
to michael z hall to be the hairy
hallucination for harrison man the whole
season of the manhunt for dexter morgan
really is an emotional roller coaster
after season 8 is like ah i guess we
won't get that and now it's like oh
maybe we'll get that um i guess we won't
get that i can't take this kind of
emotional back and forth look the
execution of the finale aside dexter new
blood as a whole i had a great time
viewing it it was an experience with a
show i hadn't had in years after i would
watch it i'd text my brother i'd call a
friend we'd talk about it every episode
that was coming to an end i could feel
it coming to an end i was like [ __ ] i
don't want this to end then the episode
would end and i would start the clock
like okay one more week let's go begin
the countdown it was a great viewing
experience and though the finale left me
unfulfilled i still have that experience
which clyde phillips and crew should see
any hate that the end of dexter new
blood gets as a compliment because
people only really hate endings that
much
if the rest of the show leading up to it
was great i really dug the show found
the ending unfulfilling as [ __ ] was my
thoughts on the season that was my
thoughts on the finale and now you know
my thoughts all right so now i'll
actually ask you dexter new blood what
did you think of the season what'd you
think of the finale whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you